our students have a wide variety of
backgrounds most of them have a passion
for the theater or a passion for some
kind of storytelling and they aren't
necessarily people who know that theater
design is a career for them maybe they
love to draw in paint or maybe they love
engineering we usually start with
probably about twenty three and design
and production design and PTM and we ask
students not to choose what area of
interest they really want to pursue
because many many people haven't had a
chance to necessarily be exposed to the
wide buffet of possibilities it's great
that if I didn't know specifically that
I wanted to do scenic design when I came
in I would have had a year and a half to
really figure that out and that time
solidified it for me even more and then
as you get older in the program you have
more responsibility you start working on
productions and a higher-up roles I'll
work with the director and all the other
designers to create a world and so what
we do in that time is has such a great
influence on what happens ultimately
when we get to rehearsal when we get to
working with actors if you're dedicated
if you love what you're doing and you
want to spend the next couple of years
working as hard as you can to be as good
as you can then I think that it's the
right fit when students graduate from
the School of Drama design or PTM if
they want to work in the field they can
and people very much value the kind of
experience that students bring to the
table from a place like CMU